officially this suspension bridge over
the river lee in cork in the south of
ireland is called daley's bridge after a
businessman who helped fund it back in
the 1920s but unofficially it has a
different name the shaky bridge because
it shakes i was going to film this with
my gopro on a stick walking across but
it's a really narrow bridge and i don't
want to end up barging into the people
who are actually using it i can confirm
from a brief experiment though
yep it's it's bouncy in the early 1700s
there was a ferry bush that actually
brought people from here and across to
the other side but unfortunately between
1906 and 1908 the dooley family actually
retired um they retired themselves from
the ferryboat industry and it was
through the philanthropy of a man called
james daly who gave nearly 700 pounds um
towards the construction of a bridge
project 700 pounds in today's term would
be around 50 000 euros
and to be honest you would not be able
to build a bridge in today's world for
50 000 euros so the bridge was good
value david rowland company um in london
and westminster um actually had a bridge
catalog and the cooperation of cork
bought a bridge off the catalogue
and in early 1927
these huge giant wooden boxes arrived in
the banks of the river lee and the
bridge actually was constructed so in
the first couple of months um the people
of the area discovered that the bridge
actually shook when they walked over us
now all suspension bridges actually
pretty much all bridges will move or
shake or sway a little as the dynamic
loads on them from people and weather
change and that's a good thing because
if they don't move a little
they break the design of this bridge
meant the shake was more obvious it
bounces up and down and it probably
wasn't intentional but clearly it wasn't
dangerous as proven by the fact that the
bridge stood for 90 years taking all the
jumping around abuse that local children
and adults could throw at it but nothing
lasts forever in 2017 an inspection
looked at the corrosion and damage that
has accumulated over the years on the
bridge and well it's been built to last
with good materials but we're near the
ocean here and 90 years of salty air and
shaking meant that the metal had
corroded and wires had broken frayed the
report said in short the bridge had
about three years before it had to be
closed and repairs were needed
immediately
so it was repaired not rebuilt the
engineers reused or matched materials as
far as possible they took the deck of
the bridge apart fixed it up off-site
and then put it back together taking
care to keep the height and positioning
the same they replaced the suspension
cables with brand new ones and repaired
the towers where they stood and they
gave the bridge a fresh coat of paint
but here's the problem this bridge is on
the local record of protected structures
it must be maintained and repaired but
it also can't be changed there was
public consultation and of course many
people actually wrote in kind of going
keep the shake keep the shake keep the
shake keep the shake and in fairness to
the engineers who worked on the project
i think they did achieve that people
have had a lot of fun walking across the
bridge admiring the river uh jumping on
it like this has been ongoing for 90
years before the work started the
engineers used accelerometers to measure
how the bridge responded to someone
jumping right in the middle and they
found that the bridge bounces up and
down at about 2.3 cycles a second so as
part of the design process they used
computer modelling to work out how the
new cables would behave and they made
sure to keep the bridge's total mass as
close as possible to how it was before
bridges shake and twist in three
dimensions of course it's not just up
and down but up and down is the
direction you feel the most when you're
standing up there and all the data
showed that in all three dimensions the
repaired shaky bridge was moving more or
less as it did before there was a slight
change but arguably that just took it
close to how it shook when it was brand
new nearly a century earlier the bridge
now goes up and down at 2.2 cycles a
second it would have been entirely
possible with modern technology and
materials to build an identical looking
bridge that was much more stable
normally that's what engineers do they
try to damp down vibrations but in this
one case their job was to keep things
the same fixing the shake would not have
been preservation the goal here was to
repair this bridge so that it can
survive and shake the residents of cork
for another century to come
you